let's go to our next caller from the
5:03 area code caller from 5:03 tell us
who you are and what's your what's on
your mind today
Trevor I want to ask what's the best way
to turn out
voter turnout on a local level like what
can we do locally to help organize and
strategize ah good okay so listen
in general voter turnout is an issue
where one of the more common reasons
people don't vote and if I'm on speaker
Trevor please take us off because I'm
hearing some weird feedback it might be
my own voice we one of the main reasons
people don't vote is they don't believe
that their vote will make a difference
from a purely mathematical standpoint
the smaller the election the more
difference any one vote is going to make
okay so I think that coming equipped
with that information and even examples
of when in local elections just a few
dozen votes one way or the other made
significant political difference I think
that that's one thing number one number
two I think it's important to relate how
voting connects to issues that are
important to that person so there are
sometimes people who aren't not voting
because they don't think their vote
makes a difference but it's because they
don't think that their vote connects
with anything that will impact their
day-to-day lives right and particularly
with local voting you're talking about
issues that will impact people's
day-to-day lives much more in some cases
than the decisions that will be made for
the president right so I think that
those are two of the best ways to get
get out the vote at the local level hmm
oh yeah definitely agreed thanks for
taking my call my pleasure Trevor
appreciate it short and sweet today Pat
yes people live we're going right one
after the other